pour la troisième fois depuis le début
de la pandémie le président macky sall
s'est adressé au peuple sénégalais cette
fois ci le chef de l'état a décidé de
présenter une nouvelle phase de la lutte
contre le co lead 19
il propose ainsi un assouplissement des
restrictions mises en place dans le pays
aujourd'hui après deux mois de mise à
l'épreuve
nous devons seulement adapter notre
stratégie en tenant compte une fois de
plus de notre vécu quotidien
dans cette nouvelle phase qui va durer
non pas quelques semaines mais au moins
trois à quatre mois nous devons
désormais apprendre à vue en présence du
virus
en adaptant nos comportements
individuels une adaptation des
comportements nécessaires face à un
virus susceptible de circuler encore
jusqu'en septembre au sein du pays
le couvre-feu mis en place depuis le 23
mars ce dernier est réduit de deux
heures à partir de ce mardi une mesure
qui s'accompagne d'un allègement des
restrictions dans les transports en
commun les commerces pour ouvrir six
jours sur sept afin de consacrer une
journée entière au nettoyage des locaux
nous avons des équipes le terrain qui
ont des engins motorisés et des objets
manuel pour lui de procéder à la
désinfection de tout ce qui est porte
tout ce qui est surface au sol tout ce
qui est rayonnages tout ce qui est à 10
pour justement éviter que le virus se
propage sur le sur les trois marchés
nous avons bien spécifiques à
l'entreprise qui est en charge de cette
mission de nous proposer un produit
efficace contre le coup du 19 mai qui
n'altère pas la santé des populations ni
valter pas la qualité des produits que
nous vendons la réouverture des lieux de
culte est également au programme afin de
permettre les prières essentiel en plein
mois de ramadan dans un pays à 90%
musulman
une partie des élèves reprendra le
chemin de l'école à partir du 2 juin
prochain
selon le président macky sall 10
millions de masques fabriqués au sénégal
seront prochainement distribués à la
population afin de limiter au mieux
l'avancée du virus